i think my marriage is over
that's the first time i've said that out
loud
you gonna say something or
i don't know what to say
well that's at first
if anybody can get through this
you can
okay
no no i'm not i'm not just saying that
you're you're
you're
tough
and uh and persistent and
decisive hmm kind of sounds like you're
calling me stubborn
yeah well
you are insanely stubborn and yeah a
little domineering uh-huh caustic maybe
yeah when i catch you before coffee time
you're downright
hostile
yeah
yeah you're not wrong yeah
so just like in general
a pretty unpleasant person yeah pretty
unpleasant yeah okay
no ted
but
you're also the most honest person that
i've ever met
and you're
strong
and smart
and funny and you're confident and
caring and you're
sexy and
um
that i didn't no i i wasn't trying that
was just me i got no i
fine i just i think that it's time to
cut the cake so
i'm just i'm gonna go inside
okay yeah
um
thank you thanks yeah
in what world did you actually think she
was gonna give you a raise i don't know
i thought you'd be like you got moxie
kid
why because she's a a 1930s hollywood
producer yes like i'm gonna put you in
the pictures see
all right sosa up
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is a stupid game for stupid people
if you want to move up the corporate
ladder you're gonna need to learn how to
play golf okay golf game all right just
hear me out okay
so
so when you when you pull the club back
you want to make a a triangle with your
arms okay hey just think of yourself as
like you're you're a pendulum okay
you're a clock
yeah but not so loose and let's please
be careful okay so next
do you can i
put my do it jonah it's only weird if
you talk about it okay all right
okay so uh
hands overlap
okay um back straight
[Music]
bend your knees
okay all right good
hey me again
where are you
if you won the lottery and are traveling
the world at least give me a call first
okay so i can cancel our table
okay
bye
good good okay now don't swing yet all
right when you come forward we're gonna
move with the power of our whole bodies
okay not just our arms and
[Music]
i am so good that was incredible who
knew i would be so good at golf i
certainly didn't team us i win yes i win
amy no you don't win amy nobody wins amy
you don't get amy
wait dude are you playing for amy
no jonah she's just in counseling it
doesn't mean her marriage is over
i know that
that's
that's exactly my
marcus keeps
oh
please save us from destruction
you
oh well
hey
sir are are we okay
look
uh
why don't we just start over
press turn
rush start
all right so
[Music]
stand up
oh god how many buttons do you have a
lot
[Music]
get down
[Applause]
wait uh
do i need a no i'm already pregnant oh
right that's awesome yeah great
[Music]
hey guys look what's on glenn it wasn't
an affair it was one kiss and it
happened because we thought we were
about to die we all thought we were
gonna die you didn't see me smooching
the first lady person i could find
weren't you praying to allah the whole
time
oh no i didn't
i am not the one on trial here you know
what nobody's on trial okay we all make
mistakes we all have lust in our hearts
it wasn't wouldn't he say lust oh i'm
sorry i don't know you guys that well
maybe you're in love then no we're not
definitely not love so you say but lord
i'm sensing something going on right
here y'all feel that right over here
hallelujah so good great this again no
uh actually we're we're dating so oh
yeah tire gauge girl okay
so
what is it guys is it love or lust all
right guys enough is enough it doesn't
matter even if they were soul mates it
doesn't make it okay look
amy is not my soul mate okay yes fine
when i first started working here
years ago
i i had a little crush on amy there i
said it okay are you happy
exactly and at one point i had a crush
on jonah and that's all in the past
exactly wait
what you when did you did
you yeah no never mind it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because if even if we
because with the timing and everything
it's yeah so you get it
so
stop
he didn't know do you still love each
other
what
and you know and
anyway it it it doesn't matter we we've
all
you know and and besides you know i've
i'm with i've got i'm with um kelly
kelly yeah no i i know your name
obviously guys
this is amazing yeah i'm generally a
cynic but this
wow she didn't know that he didn't know
and now he knows that she knows we get
it sandra i told my mom i was going to a
movie with natalie portman and she
thought i was seeing a movie with
natalie portman and she was so happy and
proud she believed you which is the
weirdest part because you are so out of
her league i am i'm completely out of
her league
well no more secrets
except
of course
yes no obviously i mean we don't you
know just until
we know right i mean we
we wouldn't want anybody to
to
hey guys
uh
so jonah and i have kind of been dating
okay hasn't that been going on for a
while
no well
yes but we've been keeping it secret now
we're announcing it yep
so
what do you want from us
nothing we just thought you'd
never mind
okay are we doing announcements i lost
my favorite pen it's a blue pen the ink
is also blue clicker cap click on it
wow i gotta say that was underwhelming
yeah i thought that'd be so much bigger
you